Talking about money issues can be emotional
and uncomfortable.
And that's why on this show,
I would like to have those conversations.
So when I heard Erin's story about her student loan debt,
I wanted to invite her here today.
Hi Erin.
Hello Drew.
Erin, will you please share your money story?
Sure.
So I'm recently engaged, planning a wedding,
I'm getting married soon.
My fiance and I have dreams of buying a home
and raising a family.
But you know, I have a lot of student loan debt,
about a hundred K in student loan debt
and then my fiance has student loan debt.
So we both had the idea to move in with the in-laws.
try to save money.
It isn't ideal, it isn't romantic, you know,
for an engaged couple,
but we're doing it because we know that our future,
it's important for our future and it's necessary.
But peeling back a layer.
Will you talk about his mom?
She's awesome.
She's a wonderful woman.
I lost my mom about five years ago,
so it's nice to have a mother-in-law
that's so welcoming and so loving and caring for me,
not being her own daughter.
What's her name?
Dee.
T?
Dee
Yeah short for Dolores.
Oh my God that's my grandmother's name.
And everybody calls me D.
So, okay I just, I loved the way you loved her.
She's just like one of those people that you meet
and is the nicest person, wouldn't hurt a fly.
Treats me like her own, you know,
she's awesome.
We're here also with our friend of the show,
Carmen Rita Wong,
and I would like to get into some of the financial aspects
now that we've established the emotional.
Carmen, are you there?
Yes lovely mama.
Oh, hi beautiful Carmen, how are you?
Good how are you?
So, you know, Erin is not the only person
obviously going through this right now
and has to sort of financially plan all of this.
Carmen,
what are your thoughts?
Listen, it's a lot, right.
But Erin, you're actually doing something very, very smart,
which is, you know, you should, at times like this,
reach out to your community, your friends, your family.
Over half of Americans,
young adult Americans,
are now back to living with their parents
or their in-laws right now.
So you are far far from alone.
So debt and money is neither bad nor good.
It's all about how you frame it.
So the frame here is be proud of yourself.
You accomplished something,
this is a monthly bill
that you're going to have to take care of,
but this is not necessarily something bad.
It's just something to manage.
How do you manage it though?
What is the plan here?
One of the easiest and best things to do with that
is to automate.
So Erin you have these student loans, right?
If you automate those payments,
you have income,
you and your fiance have income coming in.
So you know what's coming in.
If can automate those student loan payments,
you can free up a lot of mental energy,
you don't have to worry about them.
And also two,
it'll help build your credit
and some lenders will give you a little discount
on your interest rate.
Maybe a quarter of a percent.
It doesn't seem like much with loans as big as yours,
for the life of the loan,
we're talking thousands of dollars.
So that's what you definitely want to do.
You want to automate that.
And I've got some really big news for you
in terms of your fiance.
He's a public school teacher, right?
Right he's a special ed teacher.
Oh my God.
First of all, wonderful hello.
This is the thing if you work in the public sector,
you can have maybe not all your loans forgiven,
but big chunks.
We're talking over $10,000 and more.
So go encourage him or go with him to studentaid.gov.
There are multiple programs that he may qualify for
to forgive his student loans.
It's big, big money.
It's good to know. Thank you.
Have you thought about having the wedding
somewhere else or saving money on that
and is this a battle worth choosing?
Yeah. Well that's a good question.
So we had thought about a small wedding
to save money for that reason
and then it kind of just went into, you know,
but we do want that big wedding, so to speak,
but at a budget.
So we are trying to keep it low as best we can.
We all have to make decisions on what is important to us
and that cannot and should not be judged by others.
However Carmen,
do you think that she is going to have the steps necessary
to ever catch up?
Yes, absolutely.
I'm going to tell you also do another couple of things
that'll save you.
You can do today,
You can do tomorrow that can save you more money
in addition to lowering your interest rate
on your student loans as well,
there's more thousands of dollars.
Your credit card rates.
I want you to go and negotiate right?
To get to lower your credit card rates.
I want you to go and negotiate a lower car insurance,
your auto insurance too.
You mentioned watching your spending,
that's very, very important.
And this is a very emotional time for you, right?
You know, in terms of planning the wedding and all that,
be mindful of your emotions while you're spending,
all of this is going to save you some money.
I'm with drew here.
When you want to commit to something
that's going to cost a bit more,
sometimes that's like an investment in you, right?
That's an investment in your sanity,
it's an investment in your family,
it's so important to you so you can make it work
if you do the other part of it.
And it's not so overwhelming
if you take these steps day by day,
but just keep that plan in mind.
And the weirdest advice ever,
have a sense of humor about this money thing with your man.
So that every time it flares up its ugly head
that you are in it together against the world.
Yeah. It's us.
It's just us against the world.
Exactly.
What's his name?
Jim.
Jim. Yeah.
I did get a little bit interested
in some of your wedding planning.
I hope you don't mind.
I noticed that flowers seem to be a high priority for you
at your wedding.
Do you like flowers?
I love flowers.
Can I please buy your flowers for your wedding?
Yes, thank you.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
Will you please check back in with us and with Carmen.
I'm passionate about your story,
it really spoke to me
and you know your love of your mom,
and where you're at and Carmen's right,
there are so many people living with their families
and I did that with my family.
And honestly it was some of the happiest memories
I've ever had in my entire life.
Yeah. Yeah.
Erin as one of a family of six,
who also has lost her mother, I'm here for you,
I believe in you and I want you to get this done.
So after the show,
we're going to get together
and we're going to work on this.
Great. Thank you.
We're totally rooting for you and Jim.
Thank you so much for coming on the show
and sharing your story.
Thank you Drew.
Thank you Carmen
Thank you Carmen.
I love you thank you so much.
(upbeat music)